♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
RECORD NUMBER OF REPUBLICAN
WOMEN WOMEN ONE -- STEMMING THE
TIDE OF THE MEDIA’S FORECASTED
BLUE WAVE.
JOINING ME NOW TO TALK ABOUT THE
EFFECTS OF THESE EVENTS IS NEWLY
ELECTED SOUTH CAROLINA
CONGRESSWOMAN NANCY MAYS ALONG
WITH FORMER AUTHOR OF STEP UP,
HOW TO ADVOCATE LIKE A WOMAN IT.
NANCY, THANK YOU.
I SAW YOU A COUPLE OF WEEKS GO
ON ANOTHER CHANNEL AND I THOUGHT
THAT IS A VERY COOL LADY AND I
WANT TO INTRODUCE HER TO MY
AUDIENCE AS WELL.
WELCOME THEY LOVE YOU TO START
WITH TELLING YOUR STORY OF HOW
YOU GOT TO WHERE YOU ARE TODAY.
>> YEAH, THANK YOU STEVE FOR
HAVING ME ON TONIGHT.
I REALLY APPRECIATED IN IS A
GREAT AND HUMBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE A PART OF THIS VERY DIVERSE
AND INCLUSIVE FRESHMAN CLASS.
MY LIFE HAS BEEN A SERIES OF
SECOND CHANCES.
UPS AND DOWNS AND I’VE HAD AS
MANY FAILURES AND SUCCESSES.
IN FACT, I DROPPED OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL ONE OF 17 MY FIRST JOB
WAS A WAITRESS AT A WAFFLE HOUSE
ON THE SIDE OF THE INTERSTATE.
WHEN I WON THE SEAT IN NOVEMBER
I HAD MY SPEECH AND MY
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH IN THE PARKING
LOT OF THAT VERY SAME WAFFLE
HOUSE WHERE I GOT MY START.
I JOKE THAT I’M GOING FROM THE
WAFFLE HOUSE TO THE UN HOUSE BUT
SHORTLY THERE AFTER I WAS ABLE
TO GET INTO COLLEGE AND BECAME
THE FIRST WOMAN TO GRADUATE FROM
THE CITADEL MILITARY COLLEGE OF
SOUTH CAROLINA 21 YEARS AGO.
IT’S NOT JUST DEMOCRATS WOMEN
THAT HAVE A MONOPOLY ON BREAKING
GLASS CEILINGS.
REPUBLICAN WOMEN AND
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN DOING IT
ALL OUR LIVES.
IT’S VERY HUMBLING TO BE A PART
OF THE STORY THIS YEAR IN SUCH A
HISTORIC ELECTION.
IT’S EXCITING.
STEVE: ALAN, YOU’VE BEEN
FIGHTING AND CAMPAIGNING FOR ALL
OF THIS IN HELPING PEOPLE DO IT
FOR A WHILE NOW.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT IF YOU WANT
TO GO FOR IT WHAT IS YOUR
REACTION TO THE SUCCESSES WE SAW
IN NOVEMBER?
>> I’M ABSOLUTELY THRILLED.
I’M SHOCKED WHEN I SAW THAT OUT
OF THE 11000 PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EVER SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS ONLY THROUGH THE 59
HAVE EVER BEEN WOMEN AND THAT’S
3%, 21 OF OUR STATES HAVE NEVER
BEEN REPRESENTED BY A WOMAN IN
THE SENATE AND SO IT’S TIME TO
CHANGE THAT, TIME TO STEP UP AND
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT THESE WOMEN ARE
DOING.
IT’S NOT JUST WOMEN ON THE LEFT
THAT HAD THESE AMAZING STORIES.
I CANNOT WAIT FOR AMERICA TO
SHARE THE STORIES OF THE
TRAILBLAZING WOMEN THAT WE WILL
NOW HAVE IN CONGRESS.
STEVE: NANCY, TELL US SOME OF
THE ISSUES YOU PARTICULARLY WANT
TO BE FOCUSING ON AND FIGHTING
FOR ONCE YOU’RE OUT THERE IN
CONGRESS YOURSELF.
>> RIGHTS, WE CAN SEE RIGHT NOW
WITH COVID-19 THAT IS ON HEARTS
AND MINDS OF FAMILIES
EVERYWHERE, ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS, LOSS
OF BUSINESSES, LOST THEIR
LIVELIHOOD.
SOUTH CAROLINA IS A WHOLE WE
DONE A GOOD JOB OF BALANCING AND
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE AND HEALTHY
WITH GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
AND ARE ON A PLUMBING RATE
HOVERS JUST OVER NORTH OF 4%
RIGHT NOW BUT THERE ARE MANY
STATES THAT AREN’T TAKING A
SIMILAR OR SAME ACTION AND
ECONOMIES ARE CRUMBLING.
GETTING US THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
IS JOB NUMBER ONE.
ALSO ENSURING THAT AS WE LOOK AT
THIS AND SPENDING IN THE FUTURE
WE HAVE NOT HELD EACH OTHER
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OUR BUDGET
AND POLICIES AND LOOK AT THE
RISE IN THE NATIONAL DEBT AND
THE ANNUAL DEFICITS WE HAVE
EVERY YEAR AND IT’S UNTENABLE.
WE GOT TO MAKE SMART DECISIONS
IN THE FUTURE WITH TARGETED
RELIEF AND FOCUSING ON THOSE
THAT NEED IT MOST.
WE NEED TO GET OUR FOLKS BACK TO
WORK SAFELY AND THAT’S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
THE STATE LAWMAKER I’M KNOWN AS
BEING FAMOUSLY CONSERVATIVE BUT
KNOWN FOR REACHING ACROSS THE
AISLE.
I HAVE A PRISON REFORM BILL
SIGNED INTO LAW IN MY CALIFORNIA
AND COVID SO WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES WHERE I CAN FIND
SOLIDARITY WITH MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WORK ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AND SOCIAL
ISSUES AND PRISON REFORM IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
THINGS THAT WE CAN AGREE ON AND
HELP OUR COUNTRY MOVE FORWARD
AND HEAL.
STEVE: THAT’S SO GREAT.
AGAIN, NOT JUST BY BEING THERE
FOR THE WAY YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
ROLE AND SHATTERING THESE FALSE
CARICATURES THAT ARE MADE
AGAINST REPUBLICANS.
BRIEFLY ELLEN, IF SOMEONE IS
WATCHING AND THINKING I WANT TO
RUN FOR OFFICE BUT I’M NERVOUS
ABOUT IT AND WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE PRACTICAL ADVICE YOU WOULD
HAVE FOR WOMEN ON THE RIGHT WHO
WANT TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
>> THE ONE THING I WANT WOMEN TO
KNOW IS THEY JUST NEED TO TAKE
ACTION FOR THEY JUST NEED TO
BELIEVE IN THEMSELVES.
WE NEED YOUR LEADERSHIP AND IF
YOU DON’T DO IT WHO WILL?
IF WE CARE ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THIS COUNTRY AND IF WE CARE
ABOUT PROTECTING THE FREEDOM
THAT MAKES AMERICA SO
EXCEPTIONAL WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
RIGHT SPOKESPEOPLE TO DELIVER
THAT MESSAGE AND WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE RIGHT ROLE MODELS FOR OUR
YOUNG WOMEN TO LOOK UP TO SO
THIS ISN’T ABOUT VOTES FOR A
WOMAN BECAUSE SHE’S A WOMAN BUT
ABOUT WE HAVE OUTSTANDING WOMEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THOSE
STORIES ARE BEING TOLD AN
RELATABLE WAY SO NOW YOU HAVE A
FOIL TO THE AOC OF THE WORLD WHO
CAN SAY I WENT FROM WAFFLE HOUSE
TO THE U.S. HOUSE AND THEY ARE
THE ONES THAT WILL HAVE THE
POLICIES THAT ARE GOING TO BRING
OUR NEXT GENERATION OF WOMEN UP
AND SO IT’S BELIEVE IN YOURSELF
AND EVEN IF IT IS SCARY OR RISKY
JUST DO IT.
STEVE: EXACTLY.
LIKE NANCY, WERE VERY EXCITED TO